espace entre chaque personne port du
masque le conseil municipal
d'installation d'elancourt était
différent cette crise sanitaire a
provoqué des changements
un nouveau monde se prépare c'est une
refonte des méthodes de travail
une refonte des méthodes de concertation
l'impact sur l'organisation du travail
sur l'éducation sur la sécurité sur sur
le pib comment produire sur la façon de
travailler tous ensemble il ya une plus
grande concertation mondiale qu'on a vu
aussi regarder les scientifiques les
médecins qui ont travaillé en trois mois
ils ont ils ont commencé vraiment à
cerner le virus bon voilà c'est vraiment
un monde nouveau
quelque part qu'est né un nouveau monde
d'imaginer également par l'opposition la
minorité municipale étaient présentes
lors de ce conseil d'installation dix
adjoints ont été désignés nous avons une
proposition qui se cale sur le nombre
maximum d'adjoint je pense que nous
aurions pu faire un effort et avec huit
adjoints dans la mesure où il ya
également six conseillers municipaux
délégués qui sont désignés de faire un
travail efficace et sortait un signe
donné à la population
il ya des gens qui ont basculé dans la
précarité ou qui vont basculer dans la
précarité et je pense que les communes
ont un rôle à jouer pour
soutenir les familles les jeunes les
étudiants qui vont souffrir de cette
crise
durant ce conseil d'installation les
élus ont observé une minute de silence
en hommage aux victimes du coc vide 19